I have a rare genetic condition called
XP I can't go out in the Sun like I
could die hey don't want to do something
sometime would you
I'm busy during the day I can be free at
night
[Music]
there's a new haven't told him this tell
me true he deserves that we were never
gonna work
we're not the couple who doesn't try
Midnight Sun rated pg-13 in theatres
March 23rd I have this reoccurring dream
I feel the warmth of the Sun on my skin
and the comfort of arms around me and I
want to stay there forever but that
would be impossible I have a severe
sensitivity to sunlight doctor
appointments became a part of my routine
it's not gonna fall into remission and
every year the risk becomes more serious
so I spend all my time indoors behind
special windows sleeping during the day
and staying up all night and playing
music every chance I get
Hey what should I have said hey I'm
Katie Price I've watched outside my
window for the past 10 years now I've
been in love with you stalking you every
minute this is about Taylor chef does
she has awkward interactions with boys
and then she just writes amazing songs
father I don't understand how we've
never met I've probably skated by your
house every day on the way to practice
hey you would want to do something
sometime would you I'm really busy
during the day but I could be free at
night
[Music]
what does Katie Price want to do there's
so many things I wanna do he's taking me
first live show that was literally one
of the best things that are right to the
dad coming
I am not comfortable with him not
knowing I'm going to I just need a
little longer being someone more than
just a disease this isn't something you
can just not tell me I'm so sorry but
we're not the couple who doesn't try
[Music]
I'm looking at my whole life to feel
[Music]
you